for more on their first face-to-face
meeting between President Trump and
Vladimir Putin we're joined from
Washington by Douglas Olivet he's a
former director at the National Security
Council and senior fellow at New America
Douglas good morning morning John let's
start with this sort of differing
accounts that we're hearing about
whether or not there was acceptance of
Russia's role in meddling in the
elections what's your take on this well
as in any negotiation you know you come
out you try to spin the story so we've
had both the the Russians first and then
the Secretary of State come out and give
their account of the meeting there are
only six people in the meeting the the
two principals the Secretary of State
and foreign minister and the two
translators so it's not like we have a
neutral party who can tell us what
really went on so we have to rely on
these two accounts so where do we sort
of go from here when it comes to Russian
meddling in the u.s. election well
clearly this is a very sticky wicket as
they say for the president there are a
lot of Russia Hawks both in the
Democrats but also in the president's
own party who are deeply unhappy with
what happened last fall among other
thing not to mention Ukraine and Syria
and a host of other issues on which we
have disagreements with the Russians so
the president had a very narrow way to
thread this it's not clear he could have
come up with a solution that would have
made anyone happy it short of just D
railing relations with the Russians
which he clearly did not want to do so I
suppose this was about as good as we
were going to get given the president's
clear desire not to derail relations so
as you're watching this first meeting
what is your takeaway in terms of the
bigger picture issues of what this means
in terms of resetting the relationship
between the United States and Russia and
what do you anticipate about the
relationship going further between
President Trump and Putin given what
unfolded yesterday well you just have to
watch the body language between the two
men to tell that they really want this
relationship to work you know they lean
into each other the handshakes are
genuine they clearly want this
relationship to work
the list of issues on which there are
disagreements is very very long now we
do have a new special envoy appointed
for the Ukraine issue ambassador Kurt
Volker a very experienced and so that
may give an opportunity to resolve one
set of issues but the list of our
disagreements with Russia is long you
mentioned some of the issue Syria also
on the agenda yesterday where do we
stand well there's been a evidently a
negotiation going on for some time
between the United States the Russians
with the Jordanians also working about
getting a ceasefire in southwest Syria
next to the Jordanian border this is for
Syria one of the easier places to get a
ceasefire going which is not the same
thing as saying it's easy but this has
evidently been in negotiations for some
time the announcement was made yesterday
in coordination with the bilat and
there's hope that this could provide
something an initial ceasefire that then
can move into something larger at least
in this Southwest sector all right
quickly let's move to North Korea Doug I
just want to ask you President Putin has
said that while he doesn't want to see
North Korea acquire nuclear weapons he
is also not in favor of stepping up the
sort of economic consequences on North
Korea so any common ground between the
United States and Russia that you can
detect there's very little common ground
between us and the Russians and even
more importantly with the Chinese North
Korea has been a problem for a long time
this is not you know a problem that
president from created there's been a
problem for 60 years it's been a nuclear
problem for 20 years but we're now
getting to the point where it appears
they're about to reach some type of real
capability and our number of options is
very very small we don't have partners
who really see this problem the same way
we do
Douglas Oliver thank you thanks Dana